welcome back everybody to the David
Pacman show Luke Beasley here filling in
for David while he is away let's Dive
Right In well the Tennessee house
Republican effort and successful
temporarily effort to expel two out of
three of the Tennessee three as they're
being called or the Democratic State
lawmakers who protested the inaction of
Republicans on the house floor
peacefully and because of their
violation of the decorum rules they were
expelled by Republicans in the state of
Tennessee the House of Representatives
specifically and this has backfired
epically not only raising even more
attention to the fact that Republicans
are unserious about actually solving the
issues
that face Americans or citizens in
Tennessee more specifically and of
course that applies to gun violence in
such a disastrous way and it's backfired
beyond that as well because now one of
the individuals that expelled Justin
Jones has been reinstated to his
position as a Tennessee state
representative and the way that this
works and then we'll dive into some
videos from this and some reporting on
it the Nashville metropolitan council is
the entity the legislative body
um
that is responsible whenever a situation
like this takes place a state
representative is expelled the Nashville
metropolitan Council for Representatives
that represent that area is responsible
for choosing who's going to be the
interim representative so here they're
choosing Justice Justin Jones to be the
interim for uh the seat he got expelled
from
um and then he'll hold that until an
election and if he chooses to run for it
I'm sure he'll be able to actually get
back in through that as well so a
complete failure in so many different
ways on the part of the Republican party
in Tennessee
take a look at this from CNN and then
we'll look at some videos from this
after being sworn back into the
Tennessee House of Representatives
Monday a lawmaker who was expelled just
days ago over a gun control
demonstration on the chamber floor says
he'll continue to call for gun reform
quote the first thing I do when I walk
into this building as a representative
is to continue that call for common
sense gun legislation Justin Jones said
Jones and another black Democrat Justin
Pearson were forced out of the
republican-controlled legislature last
week after a protest on the chamber
floor spurred by the mass shooting last
month at a Nashville Christian School
that left six people dead a third
Democrat who joined them in the protest
and in protest representative Gloria
Johnson avoided expulsion and then it
notes there the Nashville metropolitan
Council voted 36-0 Monday to reappoint
Jones to the House of Representatives
um
putting him back into his same
previously held position and I will show
you this swearing-in here let's talk a
little bit about Justin Jones the state
representative he has just he's just now
being sworn in only moments ago being
sworn in as the new state representative
after he was expelled a few days ago
because he was protesting in favor of
gun reform and they the Republicans in
the state legislature expelled him but
now he's being he was just voted by the
city council there to be reinstated in
Nashville and now he's just been sworn
in a very very dramatic development
indeed let's talk
and credit to
the uh Nashville city council
for doing this
um
absolutely correct decision there and
then I'll show you a little bit of his
remarks out in front of the Tennessee
Capitol
that democracy will not be killed in the
comfort of Silence
hey we send a clear message to speaker
Cameron Sexton that the people will not
allow his his crimes against democracy
to happen without challenge
yeah the people of Nashville have spoken
today through their council members and
democracy we stand for the vision of a
multi-racial democracy democracy is our
is the vision we're offering to this
body this building that has forgotten it
and I've talked about this more
extensively on my show you can find that
at Luke Beasley on YouTube but just the
way that nothing represents more
accurately than what we're watching play
out in Nashville Tennessee
um the
incorrect nature of the ideology of much
of the Republican Party especially when
it comes to gun violence in the way that
we uh address gun violence and while
there are multiple fronts in which we
need to fight that battle make sure
we're uh implementing Solutions
that is a multi-faceted approach but you
can't honestly want to address
um the unique to America problem that we
have here with gun violence and ignore
the gun control element other things too
mental health too uh school safety two
all of that and gun control
and so the fact that the focus after
this mass shooting by Tennessee
Republicans was not to implement those
Common Sense Solutions but instead to
focus on expelling members who were
calling for those Common Sense Solutions
highlights the
broken nature of this ideology better
than much else for sure and then just to
round this out uh here is representative
Justin Jones walking back into the
chamber
[Applause]
[Music]
so there it is uh good for
the people of
Tennessee Justin Jones the Nashville
city council a shame on the Republicans
of course for causing this whole
situation
and we'll see how it continues to play
out
plastic it's everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year here's something super
simple you can do to reduce plastic and
help the planet a little bit our sponsor
hold on bags is the company making
plastic free trash bags and zip seal
kitchen bags they're just as strong and
high quality as the plastic bags you're
used to hold on bags are 100 percent
plant-based and home compostable meaning
they break down in just weeks not
decades their zip seal kitchen bags come
in sandwich or gallon size to fit all of
your needs whether it's carrots or
crayons at home I put all of my food
waste in a hold on trash bag throw it in
the compost pile and when I throw a hold
on trash bag in my dumpster I love
knowing it's not filling our landfills
and oceans with plastic single use
Plastics harm the planet at every Stage
production disposal decomposition join
the growing movement away from
single-use plastic these products are
really great it's so easy to make the
switch go to hold on bags.com
Pacman and you'll get 20 off with code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below